jacques chirac a été mis en examen pour
détournement de fonds publics c'est la
première fois qu'un ancien président de
la république est ainsi poursuivie en
france il est accusé d'avoir de 1983
1995 payés avec des fonds publics le
salaire d'une vingtaine de chargés de
mission qui n'aurait en fait jamais
rempli aucune mission ou était à son
service personnel cette mise en examen
pourrait donner lieu à un procès en
correctionnelle bertrand bri
les normes horloge du pôle financier
aura compté trois heures avant que
jacques chirac ne s'éclipse loin des
caméras ce matin il laisse le soin à son
avocat d'annoncer sa mise en examen pour
détournement de fonds dans la sphère des
chargés de mission de la ville de paris
il est pas forcément mécontent d'avoir
pour la première fois l'occasion de
s'expliquer sur ce dossier ce serait
certainement épargner cela si cela avait
été possible mais compte tenu de la
lourdeur de l'instruction du nombre de
dénonciations qui ont eu lieu du nombre
de dénonciations qui ont eu lieu il
était bien certain qu'un jour ce rendez
vous se tiendrait cette fois ci la juge
d'instruction xavière simeoni avait
convoqué l'ancien chef de l'état
directement au pôle financier comme un
justiciable ordinaire contrairement à
une précédente audition dans une autre
affaire qui avait eu lieu au bureau de
jacques chirac
les faits remontent aux années 80 90
jacques chirac cumule alors les
fonctions de maire de paris et chef du
rpr sous ses ordres
la mairie aurait rémunéré des dizaines
de chargé de mission secrétaire dactylo
chauffeurs payées sans travailler tout
pour travailler ailleurs en particulier
auprès de personnalités de droite ou de
membres de son cabinet jacques chirac
aurait ainsi signer lui-même
l'embauchent du chauffeur d'un ancien
préfet de paris lucien l'allier qui
n'avait rien à voir avec la mairie de
paris dans une tribune libre adressé au
journal le monde l'ancien président
assure qu'il n'y a eu ni système ni
enrichissement personnel et endosse la
responsabilité de ces recrutements
ces recrutements je les ai souhaités
autorisés parce qu'ils étaient légitimes
autant que nécessaires
six mois après son départ de l'elysée
l'ancien chef de l'état risque désormais
dans ce dossier un procès en
correctionnelle
reportage de bertrand boyer et de daniel
petitcuenot zh